welcome to this video new video in the
series on endgame strategy this is a
game neiderhoff
playing white meat one night off very
much known to this day for the night of
variation I'm playing yuri arabic also
well-known name
he invented the auerbach system against
the kings in nature sometimes play with
with the success of a buck in fact it's
the oldest living Grandmaster I think
he's more than 90 years old this game is
from 1953 the famous zurich candidates
tournament and the key position comes up
after youth what is it
twenty-something 21 um we had some
exchanges really going to the endgame at
this point but I want to quickly show
how it came to this position with a
slight move all the wrinkle we capture a
main line of the Queen's Indian defense
94 this position is popular until the
stay on white nowadays mostly plays
Bishop d2 in this position but Queen c2
remains popular and like took and here
young knight office playing a slightly
curious move he plays a B take c3 which
is nowadays completely uncommon
everybody plays Queen takes c3 simply of
keeping the pawn structure sound yeah he
took with the pawn and while this should
not prove fatal
I think it shows that he's a bit bit too
relaxed maybe about the pawn structure
we see that following these moves
why does not verse 2 exchanges and every
traitor is definitely not in in White's
famous with trading more pieces those
weak pawns and squares on the queenside
can become effective it's not yet
something dramatic but the the tendency
of the game is already shifting a bit
towards black d6 was played here it's
important to note that the at first very
appealing move on knight c6 it's not
helping right at all after Queen e8 it's
in fact Wyatt who's in a pin and very
likely he will have to give up the night
for the bishop on his 7 which is
something that Y does not want to do
giving up this also means that you're
having this Bishop on c1 against the
knight on b7 and this night can be very
useful on the light squares and against
this pawn on c4 we will see some of that
later that this piece distribution is
not very very welcome for white we see
this late as mentioned white went back
to d3 which is also debatable it's maybe
more prudent to go here to have this
covering available at some time so night
I was playing a couple of substandard
moves and this is at the end leading to
his his troubles when c5 this is what he
had planned with 93 but it's very
important to note that after c5 black is
of course not obliged to capture at all
one problem is that every pawn capture
from the white side on d6 or p6 only
leads to to the C pawn being weak on
half-opened far we will see that later
Queen e8 very good and typical move the
white queen on a form is an act of peace
and should be exchanged and what cannot
really avoid the trait
if white wants to keep the Queen's on he
yeah has to reckon with this capture
here something like this yeah of course
not the capture this would leave black
with with weaknesses you rather play d5
in this position yeah putting those
pawns on the on light squares allowing a
possible night here and it's clear that
the c5 pawn is sister Minh Utley week
this will fall sooner or later what you
want is to play on the light squares
this light squares have been weakened a
lot by the double corn we go back the
double pawn here is a weakness
especially after the trade of the
LightSquared Bishop swith every trade
this pawn against weekend we go in the
game
white needed to trade as mentioned and
now what's really facing this problem
what to do with this e5 pawn he kept the
pressure on very long and didn't take
good decision but after rook c8 h4
yeah this may be intense Bishop g5 at
some point d5 Bishop f4 f6 this is one
of those little moves that show that
black has some firm understanding of the
position he wants to get the King
involved he takes away a good square
yeah black is absolutely never going to
take here yeah this is not in US
interest at the moment the knight on a
five then also would be somewhat
stranded might go to see forward the
thing is white does not want to take on
b6 absolutely not and we can delay this
capture to to a good movement so f6 is a
good strengthening move night before
plate and a six so that the knight
cannot counter it
and we approaching the critical position
takes things ripe now felt obliged to
take yeah I probably he couldn't
couldn't really yeah
find the strength to play 93 this is
also very unattractive at the further
point of the move f6 you know just a
very good strengthening and preparations
to get also the center ruling yeah white
right took on one be 680 in this
position we come to come to a critical
critical point um yeah what are the
features of this position the pawn on c4
now is it's not existing anymore it went
to c5 and exchange itself but the
problem with this the setup is that
there's an A to C pawns and now the c3
pawn this week it's on a half-open farm
and the weakness and of course still the
light squares very much of a problem
however in this position it's white to
move and the the big question is what
should white do here should TM cover the
c3 pawn should he move the knight if you
move the knight to d3 you have a
counter-attack against b6 so rooks III
rook b6 it's not something that we fear
at all as black we have now traded this
the weak c3 pawn against the b6 pawn
after 93 black will probably play b5 and
still black is better there's no doubt
about that
Black has the pressure and he has a good
night coming to see form yeah he's got
the better Bishop on his 7 in relation
to the pawn structure you know the
points here on light squares while the
bishop is on a dark square and
is a dark-squared bishop and there are
many dark square oops many pawns on dark
squares like this and especially these
all this adds up to a definite advantage
from like however it's not clear if like
and how like is going to going to
convert this in the game night off plate
to move Bishop d2 and this move is some
is a mistake the reason is why this is a
mistake
is that after Bishop d2 black can play
Knight c4 and I went to Bishop to you
want there this does not look very
attractive but they're really yeah
they're they're no better squares away
in a bill Iranian Bishop you want and
now the next move is very important and
the key why this Bishop d2 move was was
not advisable black now takes on before
this is not a move that comes natural
for for some players why would you take
the knight here with your perfectly fine
Bishop but however if you take a closer
look or have some more experience in an
endgame positions or this kind of
strategical decisions it is a clear fact
that the strength of minor pieces is
very often emphasized if you exchange
down to two very distant difference of
of strength of pieces what I'm trying to
say is after this and white white and
the game captured with the pawn let's
put it on the board that now we only
have one pair of minor pieces one night
sorry about that one night against one
Bishop and this kind of difference in
strength as the knight is much much
stronger than the bishop is often
easier to convert than an advantage of
if we go back of two minor pieces each
where yes this night is better than this
Bishop but this is more complicated in a
situation like that the white night for
example in the long run might be able to
challenge the light squares
you know let's say Knight c2 to e3 it
looks a bit strange at the moment but it
could fight for the light squares and do
something on them while in the game
after the straight the light squares now
are totally weak and absolutely
uncontested by white so very often
strategical advantage of an advantage in
in quality of the pieces gets emphasized
by the right trades here black against
rid of his bishop and establishes a
night where this bishop scenario in a
very close position where the knight is
simply the much better piece especially
if it's such a dummy bishop here only
one yeah how should white eke he take us
with the porn in the game young this
opens the C file and this nothing
nothing great but Luke takes is not much
much better it still stays a very
attractive position for black
how should black play though and well
this is some also and game strategy what
should like - yeah black him has a
number of number of plants that you can
combine and very often you don't really
play am a super straightforward plan
that is netting you the win like you
think about it for 10 minutes and then I
say okay first I do this and I do that
and then I do this and then he's
breaking the position is breaking apart
this is very often not happening what
you do is you play some moves that
strengthen your position and very often
this buildup of little things sort of
gets a snow morning effect and your
position becomes
so over bombing that the other side is
somewhat is breaking apart on itself and
the other side they they can make
mistakes very often it's just good to
make a couple of strengthening moves and
then let them make the mistakes and and
yeah and let them make the decisive
changes it's a well-known fact that in
passive positions it's easy to make bad
moves here for example I would recommend
that black should play moves like h5 for
example this is a very typical good move
it fixes this pawn on a dark square and
make sure that those pawns are not
moving king f7 is a typical move that is
improving blacks position activating the
King a bit what should you do on the
Queen side what you can do is you can
just keep it for the moment as the nylon
c4 is ideally placed it always covers
the b6 pawn this makes any pressure on
the B file basically meaningless black
also can think of a plan with b5 and
maybe Knight b6 to a4 let me get rid of
some of the markets like B 596 Knight a
for attacking the c3 pawn also an idea
you should slowly build up here another
key idea for black can be at the right
moment to play play get rid of this to
play e5 yeah not right away but first
prepare things King f7 rook c6 rupee
eight those kind of moves are easily
playable as Black is also enjoying a
slight advantage in space you have more
room to maneuver and can improve your
position first as a typical do not rush
scenario we shouldn't do something
something some drastic quickly it's not
necessary we can first
improve our pieces in the game he takes
with the pawn and now it's clear we're
on winning ideas on the C file 93 rupee
395 this force is III
this was not the only way to proceed but
a very good one
III Roxy - we invade on the C file yeah
note that how this exchange on before
has clarified the situation tremendously
this is a very very clear and distinct
advantage we have the C file we have the
better minor piece this is enough for
win with a good good technical play a
496 yeah this night has many good
squares C for I'm sick of this sorry I'm
going to keep pressing this button
because in the other software you need
to press the button to draw to draw an
arrow simply cannot adjust to that there
is this square there's efore possibly on
or f5 yeah this night has has many
options where they can go to a five
that's debatable
it looks a bit a bit silly to put
another poll on dark square but rook a
to was probably coming anyway to force
that so not a big deal on b5 rooks e3
yeah there's really not much else Group
C eight yeah and we have this straight
on the sea phone
what's position is really a beyond
repair we cannot really find any any big
improvement yeah Knight to e7
where does is it heading at can go to c6
attacking in the spawn or to f5 here
looking at at those weaknesses and three
was basically necessary otherwise you
never get your stuff out here should one
you one especially bishop f2 was played
yeah if white try something like rook F
to you're running into this pin you know
it's also a very attractive position
from like now we're taking on before
King to g2 let's say and then if I this
coming takes takes and again we come
here here it's a it's just an
overwhelming advantage the before pawn
is weakened all-white spawns
potentially potential targets here we
are even not even forced to get the King
in first black would have had the time
but we here can definitely force matters
even more even more quickly white went
Bishop F to King f7 and now the nidus is
coming around again going to this this
great square on c4 yeah white really ism
is in a terrible shape
what should you play a played King here
and now we play went f5 yeah like has
many ways yet to proceed another very
typical way would have been a five
you're getting this this pawn involved
if why it takes takes we are almost in a
super swung situation what should white
play here
yeah something like this runs into a
double attack them when f3 and b3
yeah if you move the rook this is going
to be taken it's just slowly drifting
into enters of this one if five however
is accomplishing almost the same thing
what she really has no move if you play
something like this for example there is
night b2 with 91 coming you know to move
the king that's 92 we had this at this
before he went here at this way needed
to give up the pawn king g1 y and now
black simply could have retreated to c4
he went for a different solution which
is also good when F for protecting the
night after the capture he went to f5
which leads to a very sorry looking
positioner weak weak weak weak weak all
white spawns a week while black has no
problems whatsoever
he is dominating on the see file in the
text on weaknesses King f1 was played g6
not keeping this pawn on a dark square
root B 3 King 7b1 King D 7 and here
neither of resigned I guess this was
some adjourned at this state and he
resigned him because he had seen that
any further resistance was was useless
yeah how does black convert him most
easily the easiest way to do it is to
play rook c4 and just take on d4
let's say white plays not sure what
exactly making him then something like
this is it's very easy
we attack here and just take the pawn
yeah you don't want to get rid of this
you don't want to allow white to
exchange this but the advantage is just
so overwhelming that we're that we can
easily do that like this for example
yeah what has to cover this cover this
he cannot afford to now shuffle on the B
far we go here and then here the King
comes this is simply too much and also
very easy to play this is why Knight of
resigned one key moment in the game the
key moment in the game was one like to
convey form and this is why I chose this
this example it's very important to
notice that this kind of trade can be
keep exchanging pieces that don't really
help you in your position the bishop one
is seven against and I don't before to
emphasize the advantage that you have in
the remaining pieces like here the night
over the bishop this is very often
assumed as a helpful device to exchange
the right pieces to make sure that you
actually can make any headway with the
the things that are remaining on the
board yeah I hope you enjoyed this
example and yeah there will be new
episodes of course of the series coming
up I welcome any feedback in the
comments thanks for watching